[موسيقى]
تحيه طيبه مشاهدي الكرام الم يكن وزير
الخارجيه الروسي لافروف على حق عندما قال
ان الحرب في اوكرانيا صارت اليوم بشكل
مباشر مع الغرب وليس مع اوكرانيا الم
يعترف الرئيس الامريكي بعظمه لسانه بان
ارسال الدبابات والطائرات الغربيه الى
اوكرانيا بدا يجعل منها حربا عالميه
بامتياز الا تلجا امريكا واوروبا الى
تصعيد خطير مع روسيا اليس من حق الروس ان
يستجمعوا قواهم للرد على هذه الهجمه
الغربيه السافره بعد ان اتحد الغرب ضدهم
الا تعني خساره الحرب بالنسبه للروس
تهديدا وجوديا لبلدهم اليس من حقهم اليوم
ان يلجاوا الى كل الوسائل لمواجهه هذا
الخطر الوجودي
لكن في المقابل الا يبقى الدعم الغربي
لاوكرانيا ضعيفا ورمزيه رغم كل هذه الهيصه
الاعلاميه الفارغه ماذا يستفيد
الاوكرانيون من الدبابات الامريكيه اذا
كانت ستصل بعد سنه الا يواجه الجيش
الاوكراني الروسي بمفرده ويلحق بهم خسائر
فادحه اليست تهديد الروسي بالسلاح النووي
بين الحين والاخر دليلا على هزيمه روسيا
وضعفها الم يكن يبشرنا الروس وابواقهم
بالانتهاء من الحرب خلال ايام الم تدخل
بعد ايام سنتها الثانيه وهم غارقون في
الوحل الاوكراني ماذا ستفعل موسكو فيما لو
دخل الغرب فعلا ارض القتال هل تستطيع
مواجهه الجميع وهي فاشله في مواجهه
الاوكرانيين فقط
اسئله ونطرح و عبر الاقمار الصناعيه من
كيف على الدكتور محمد فرج الله رئيسي
تحرير وكاله اوكرانيا بالعربيه و عبر
الاقمار الصناعيه من موسكو على الدكتور
نواف ابراهيم المستشار السياسيه والاعلامي
نبدا نقاش بعد الفصل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مره ثانيه مشاهدينا الكرام نحن
معكم في برنامج الاتجاه المعاكس دكتور
نواف ابراهيم لو بدات معك من موسكو الا
تعتقد ان هناك الكثير من المبالغه عندما
نسمع وزير الخارجيه الروسيه لافروف وهو
يقول ان الحرب الان لم تعد باي حال من
الاحوال بيننا وبين اوكرانيا بل صارت حربا
حقيقيا بيننا وبين الغرب هل يعقل انه
الغرب تحول الى العدو الرئيسي لروسيا الان
مساء الخير دكتور فيصل لك والمشاهدين
والمشاهدين الكرام والدكتور محمد فرج الله
يعني نحن نتحدث عن امر وقع سابقا منذ زمن
بعيد ونحن نرى ونتابع انا الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وضعت نصب عينها ان تدمر
روسيا وهذه الحرب العالميه التي يتم
الحديث عنها هي بدات صراحه من عام 2011
بما يسمى بالربيع العربي وعندما فشلت
مخططات الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في هذه
المنطقه قولا واحدا ارادت ان تذهب باتجاه
الخطه التي كانت تشغل بال العالم والخبراء
العالميين اجمعهم وكانوا يختلفون على
لكنها ومضمونها وكانت هي المخرج من
البوابه الاوكرانيه للوصول الى روسيا قبل
الزمن المحدد لذلك يا سيدي نحن ما نتابعه
من الضغوط السياسيه والعسكريه والتسليح
والضغط في كل الاشكال همم الضغط على روسيا
همم لا يدل على ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ودول غير هي التي تعتدي يا سيدي
منطقه باخموت بعيد عن روسيا 130 كيلو متر
او عن حدودها وبعيده عن الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه سمينه الاف 400 كلم روسيا من
حقها وبالقانون الدولي ووافق كل الاعراف
هي ان تكون في موقف دفاعي عن نفسها اما
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه التي كانت
تعتبر ان هذا الامر هو لعبه كما كان في
المنطقه الشرق الاوسط وفي العراق
افغانستان لعبه استثمار كما تعودنا عليها
الان اصبحت بعد ان راينا وشاهدنا كيف ان
روسيا تحقق تقدم وهذا بناء على تقارير
خبراءته الذين قالوا ويقولون الان في
تقاريرهم ان التقديرات التي كانت قد وضعت
في انهيار روسيا وصمود اوكرانيا ومقاومتها
العسكريه سوف تؤدي الى انهيار الاقتصاد
الروسي والذي وضع له مرحله اولى في عام
2022 بقى لها سينهار الى 30% ومن ثم بشكل
هائل في عام 2023 بالمقابل
ارتفع موقف روبل ثمانيه بالمئه مقابل
الدولار و18 مقابل اليورو والناتج
الاجمالي المحلي وفق تقارير النقد الدولي
او صندوق النقد الدولي انها تصل الى
2.3% لماذا اتحدث على الاقتصاد لان
العمليه الحقيقيه والحرب الحقيقيه التي
كانت هي انهاء روسيا اقتصاديا هم كانوا
يعلمون تماما ان روسيا تطورت خلال السنوات
ال 20 الماضيه ووقفت على ساقيها بمعدل لا
يتجاوز
3.2 من الناتج الاجمالي لاوروبا والمحيط
الانجليزي وكوريا الجنوبيه واليابان
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه هون وصلوا
الى مرحله من القلق على مستقبلهم وعلى
عوده روسيا الى الساحه الدوليه ونحن نعلم
تماما كيف كان الرئيس في عام 2007 في
مؤتمر ميونيخ للامن وتحدث عن تغير العالم
والقطب الواحد لذلك هم اراده ان ينهوا
عسكريه همم روسيا اقتصاديه
جدا الحرب واستنقاذ اوكرانيا لتكون
اوكرانيا محطه لهم في منطقه شرق اوروبا
جميل جدا
دكتور دكتور دكتور دكتور
خلينا ناخذها نقطه نقطه دكتور محمد في
كييف
انتم
بعباره اخرى كما يقول الدكتور نواف من
موسكو يعني انتم عباره عن اداه في حرب
غربيه عالميه تشن الان على روسيا كيف ترد
على كلامه وان الحرب بيوقع الامر الحرب
على روسيا لم تبدا قبل عام عندما دخلت الى
اوكرانيا ودخل ضدها الغرب بل بدات قبل
حوالي عقد من الزمالك كيف ترد
تحيه لكم دكتور فيصل لضاحك الكريم والمشهد
الكريم طبعا كالعاده دائما نسمع من كل
موسكو المنطق المقلوب يا سيد الكريم
الحقيقه ما يلي طالما يعني طالما يدعي
الضيف الكريم بقى بان روسيا هي تعرض
لمؤامره لماذا قدم بوتين بيديه وبجيشه
ورمى نفسه بهذا الوحل اذا كان يعلم بوتن
بان بلاده مستهدفه واعتقد بانه سيدخل
التاريخ بوتن كافشى لرئيس روسي منذ 300
عام اذا كان يعلم بوتن ويعتبر دولته عظمه
وهي ليست عظمى الناتج القومي لروسيا اقل
من كوريا الجنوبيه الحادي عشر عالميا لا
يرقى ان يكون حتى نصف قطب اذا كان يعلم
بان الغرب بيتربص به وينصب له الفخ لماذا
رمى نفسه بهذا الفخ الحقيقه مختلفه تماما
الحقيقه بانه وهناك فساد خطير في روسيا
هنالك انهيار واله برو روسيه 20 عاما صنعت
كذبت ما يسمى الجيش الثاني عالميا واستمرت
كره الثلج بالتداور اكثر واكثر وعمليه
بناء هذه البروفاغندا حتى بوت النفس
الدقها وعندما قام به طبعا بالغزو 24
فبراير الذي يسميها عمليه خاصه لا ادري
عمليه خاصه كل الدوله من خمسه بها الروسيه
وتورط والقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه نزعت
ورقه التوت عن هذا الجيش الكرتوني الذي
الان اكثر من 1700.000 من اشياء هي
متناثره في اجزاء مختلفه من اوكرانيا بدا
يئن وبدا يقول ان الغرب يحاربه الم يقل
بايجن منذ نوفمبر عام
2021 بان روسيا تحشد بايضا يحذر بان روسيا
تحت ثلاث شهور وهنالك معلومات استخباراتيه
بريطانيه وكنديه وامريكيه بان روسيا على
الحدود اذا الامريكي لم يجر روسيا لهذه
المستنقع روسيا جرت نفسها بوت صدق نفسه
بعد الانتصارات الكرتونيه
بعدما جرب طبعا بشاعه جيشه في سوريا وفي
ليبيا على اطفال ونساء عزل صدق نفسه بعدما
خرج الامريكان من افغانستان وبلع الطعم
ورما بنفسه بالحرب وعندما بدا الجيش
الروسي يتحمل الهزيمه والهزيمه وعندما سحق
باول هذه مخذيه في اقليم تياب والهزيمه
الثانيه في اقليم تشرنجه والهزيمه الثالثه
في اقليم سومي والهزيمه الرابعه في اقليم
ثم في ثم في خرسون بدا يتحدث بان الغرب
يواجهه لا هو في البدايه كان يدعي بان
الغرب في حين نذكر القاء المستمع الكريم
المشاهد بان مكرون وشيلسي ذهب الى بوت قبل
الحرب وحاول الاتفاق مع ولكن بوتن صدق
نفسه
موضوع الاقتصاد نعم الان بوتن سيعيد فعلا
الاقتصاد الروسي العصر الحجري كل الاثار
والاقتصاديه التي حققها بوتن او روسيا في
20 عاما وروسيا 70% من داخلها يعتمد على
مبيعات النفط والغاز وكان اكبر مكسب لها
السيل الشمالي واحد واثنين تفقده روسيا في
اقل من عام اما موضوع الروبل هذه كذبه بوت
الان لو بعثت اي واحد في موسكو يريد ان
يشتري روبل بالسعر الدولار عفوا بالسعر
المعلن لن يشتريه سيدفع الربلات ويحصل على
رقم على الموبايل الكترونيا ثم يقول له
تعالى بعد اسبوع استلم 100 دولار او 200
كل هذه اليوم عمليه كله كذب روسيا باعتراف
شركه جاز بروم انخفاض مستوى بيع الغاز في
اقل من عام الى 42% روسيا الان محاصره
اقتصاديا روسيا الان معز دوليا وهذه
المكتسبات بماذا بالغباء البوتيني الذي
رمى به ولا يريد ان يعترف بالخطا ويخرج
وطبعا الرئيس التركي اردوغان رمى له طوق
النجاه مرتين للتفاوض معزنسكي وعندما فوجئ
طبعا وفوج العالم ايضا بالشجاعه
الاوكرانيه وبدا الغرب يحمل على المحمل
الجد ان الشعب الاوكراني والقوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه جديره بنوع مختلف هنا جنه جنه
بوتن لانه فقط
بالسلاح القديم الجيش الاوكراني اوجع
الجيش الروسي فما بالك عندما سيستلم
تشالنجر اثنان وليفارد اثنان وابرز واحد
يعلم بوتن بان الهزيمه قادمه له اما
بالنسبه لاوكانيا
بس دكتور محمد سناتي عليها سناتي عليها
ناخذها وحده وحده لو سمحت
يعني دكتور فيصل بس خليني اسالك مشان هناك
نقاط تفضلت فيها دكتور نواف الان انتم كما
يقول الدكتور محمد بن كياف يعني يعني هيصه
اعلاميه كبيره وحرب اعلاميه والى ما هنالك
الغرب يستهدف روسيا روسيا مستهدفه منذ زمن
طويل
والخطه بالف فشلت في في الربيع العربي
والخطاباء جاءت الى اوكرانيا انا بدي
اسالك يعني هل تعتقد ان هناك شخص دكتور
نواف يمكن ان يصدق هذه الاكاذيب الربيع
العربي كان ضد روسيا من الذي ادخل روسيا
الى سوريا وسلمها الميه الدافئه بس خليني
اسال لك من الذي سلم روسي المياه الدافئه
هل كانت تحلم روسيا بدخول المياه الدافئه
عن طريق سوريا لولا امريكا امريكا لو كانت
فعلا تستخدم الربيع العربي
ان الى سوريا اولا فلا تضحك على الناس
بموضوع انه الربيع العربي كان ضد روسيا
روسيا استفادت وهي تنهد سوريا
وتدمر سوريا منذ بدايه الحديث يا دكتور
فيصل
تفضل يعني انت كل مره في كل حلقه نخرج
اليها تذهب الى موضوع بعيد تماما عن
الحلقه التي نحن نلتزمها
لحظه شويه يا دكتور فيصل لا لا انا دخلت
بالاطار العام ولما ادخل في التفاصيل اذا
اردت ان تتحدث في التفاصيل كنا تحدث بدايه
تسميني وانا ضيفك اننا نحن ابواق روسيا
وصديقك يقول اننا نحوه
وتستهزء الى ما هنالك هذه الالفازيا اصلا
انا اريد ان اتحدث
دكتور فيصل جاوبني
هلا
ساجيبك اتفضل ساجيبك لكن لا تاخذني
بالعبطه وتهينني ومن ثم تطرح عليه سؤال
حتى تقول عني اني كاذب وهل احد يصدق هذه
يا سيدي اقول لك اقول لك ان من اجل الروبل
او ما يحدث للركوب والاقتصاد هذه التقارير
من منظمات دوليه فليقرا السيد الدكتور
محمد فرج هذه التقارير وتقارير صندوق
النقد الدولي ولا يقرا ما كتبته الجريده
تايمز ذا تايمز يوم امس عندما قالت ان
الخساره الكبرى التي توقعناها لروسيا هي
تمنى بها بريطانيا والدول الاتحاد
الاوروبي الان وصلت الى مرحله من
الاقتصادي لا تستطيع اصلا ان تنهض بنفسها
لكي تطعم شعوبها ولكن تغطيهم من الغاز
الذي كان يمر ميسي
اتفقنا عن الموضوع الحلقه
الدكتور محمد انت تقول ان الغرب انها
تحولت الى حرب عالميه ضد روسيا تحولت الى
حرب عالميه ضد روسيا طيب الدكتور محمد
يسالك من الذي وقع بالفخ من الذي غزا
اوكرانيا في المقام الاول من الذي ذهب
برجليه ليقع في هذا الفخ اذا كان هناك فخر
به كيف ترد
يا سيدي نحن بالنسبه للحرب وحتى واجيب لك
واعطيني الوقت لو سمحت هو باختصار شديد
بالنسبه للحرب كانت الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هي التي وضعت توقيت الحرب والتي
هي جيشت وسائل الاعلام الغربيه والوسائل
التابعه لها وعاش العالم كله الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه وهي لم تحدث حتى وقعت
فعلا والولايات المتحده الامريكيه او
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه اذا كان يتذكر
الدكتور محمد فرج يوم امس 29 شهر منذ 105
اعوام كانت هناك حرب حقيقيه ما بين
جمهوريه اوكرانيا الشعبيه وما بين روسيا
سوفياتيه ويعرف تماما كيف انتهت هذه
المعركه وكيف انتصرت روسيا الان المعركه
تختلف تماما والحرب تختلف تماما هي حرب
فعلا على روسيا وعلى هذا العالم يا سيدي
عندما يتحدث عن ايام الحجر في كورونا
فليسال زملائه الالمان كيف كانت في
الليالي تتحرك اعداد هائله من الدبابات
لتصل الى اوكرانيا كيف كان يصل الظلام
الاسلحه والدبابات والمقاتلين
كيف انهم قاموا منذ اعوام او منذ اخيه
بوليس اقول لك منذ يوليو لا تموز 2022 ما
الذي وقع وضعت المخابرات المركزيه
الامريكيه ما يعادل مساحه 6 ملاعب كره قدم
من الاسلحه والذخائر حتى كشفتها روسيا ومن
ثم صرحت روسيا واتصلت او تواصلت القياده
الروسيه مع بولندا وحذرتهم من مغبه
الاستمرار في هذا العمل والدخول في معهد
هذه المعركه
البولنديين ليقولوا اننا نحن لم نكون
راضيين عن المعركه او العمليه الروسيه في
اوكرانيا ولكن لم نصرح باننا سوف نقوم
بتصليح ركائنا وهذه كانت رساله واضحه الى
كل دول الغرب والى كل دول اوروبا اريد ان
اقول لك امر اخر ومهم جدا الدبابات التي
نتحدث عنها والتي اعدادها تفوق باعداد
التي يتم التصريح عنها اقول لك انه هناك
هناك تصنيع لغذائف تعمل بجي بي اس وهذه
الغذائف هي مصنوعه بشكل خاص للطائرات
الروسيه الموجوده لدى اوكرانيا وهي وزنها
يصل من 2000 الى همم من 200 الى 2000 همم
انجليزي كما يقال بهذه التسميه وهناك ايضا
عمليه محاوله لتسخير هذه الطائرات
الموجوده الروسيه في اوكرانيا لاعاده
الهجوم المعاكس على روسيا واستعاده
الاراضي التي تم السيطره عليها اقول لك
اكثر من ذلك الاموال التي تم ضخها
والتسليح العسكري التي تصرح الان كل دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي بولندا يوم امس صرح بانه
يمكن ان يكون من السجاجه التفكير بان
التغيرات التي سوف تطرا على الاوضاع
والعلاقات في الاتحاد الاوروبي هو الوضع
السياسي ل بولندا بانها ستكون ايجابيه هذا
امر غير معقوله وسيؤثر على كل مستقبلها
وموقفها السياسي عندما يخرج ايها الوزير
المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الصينيه يقول ان
المبادره الكبرى والاكبر للحرب في
اوكرانيا هي كانت على الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه واذا كانت تريد الحفاظ على
الشعب الاوكراني فمن الافضل التفكير بعدم
توليد السلاح اقول لك اكثر من ذلك
محمد دكتور دكتور
الامريكيه عن التسليح دكتور نواف سلامه
جميل جدا دكتور نواف جميل جدا دكتور محمد
دعكه من كلامه روسيه
دكتور محمد دكتور محمد
هل انا اصدقك ام اصدق الرئيس الامريكي
الذي قال في الخامس والعشرين من هذا الشهر
قبل سته ايام بالضبط قبل سته ايام
قال بالحرف الواحد وهي مصوره لو كان عندي
شريط كنت فرجيته قال بالحرف الواحد
ايها الامريكيون ايها الغربيون هل تعتقدون
ان ارسال الدبابات والطائرات والطيارين
الامريكيين والغربيين الى اوكرانيا هذه
مجرد لعبه لا لا لا لا لا ليست مجرد لعبه
قالها بالانجليزي
الحق ولذ الجانب الروسي الحق بالقول ان
روسيا الان اصبحت هدفا استراتيجيا واساسيا
للعدوان الغربي الامريكي والاوروبي كيف
ترد تفضل
اذا انا ارد على سؤال لو سمحت الدكتور
نواف رائع جدا سيد الكريم هذه الفرصه
الذهبيه التي حصل عليها الغرب هي نتيجه
عكسيه تماما لما اراده بوتا وهذه فرصه
جاءت لكي يؤذب الغرب بوتن وروسيا ويحطها
في حجم الحقيقي بالنسبه لاوكرانيا
اوكرانيا حتى الان دوله دافع عن نفسها
ودوله متمسكه بالسياده وكما قال دكتور
فعلا جمهور اوكرانيا الشعبيه مهمه 1921
وهي اول جمهوريه استقلت عن روسيا القيصريه
1918 وعاشت ثلاث سنوات وكان اول اتفاق
يعترف شرف بين القوميه الاوكرانيه
والروسيه بانه بعد الاطاحه بالقيصر
الاوكرانيين يعيشون بامان وسلام والرموس
وسلام وما ان استقر الحكم للشيوعيون
بالروس اغرق اوكرانيا بالدماء في عام 920
وهنا الاوكرانيون عالموا بان هذه الدوله
اسمها روسيا لا شرف ولا امانه ولا اي قيمه
لها بالاتفاق وعندما احتلت اوكرانيا من
اتحاد السوفيتي وحصلت على استقلالها عام
91 هذه المره الثانيه بدات تقيم كل ما
تريده وعندما فاضت الشعب الاوكراني في عام
2013 وخلعوا العميل الروسي الرئيس
الاوكراني السابق المخلوع جنابه وبدات
اوكرانيا تقوم بخطوات بخفازات سريعه نحو
التطور والديمقراطيه والرفاهيه هنا بوتن
اي قناه بانه اما ان يغزوا اوكرانيا
ويعيدها الى التخلف الروسي اما تكون
اوكرانيا اقوى حليب غربي في المنطقه ولم
يختار الطريقه الصحيحه
فقام بالطريقه اللام منطقيه والغبيه وهي
الغزو الان الامريكيين راقبوا الموقف في
البدايه وذكر عندما بدا الغاز وفي
فبراير22 الاستخبارات ايتيه وضعت تقريرا
وتو- وتشخيص الموقف بان كيف تسقط خلال 72
ساعه واوكرانيا خلال اسبوع عندما قاوم
الاوكرانيون لوحدهم بسلاحهم الموجود ولم
يعدوا شهر ونصف فوجئ الامريكيون وراوا بان
ما استثمروها في الجيش الافاغاني وهزم في
اسابيع مع طالبان هنالك قوات مسلحه اخرى
جديره اكثر بالاحترام وهي القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه فبدا الدعم منذ ابريل والرئيس
الاوكراني زينسكي رفض ان يغادر كيف ودخل
التاريخ كشخص مدافع عن نفسه هنا بدا هنالك
رايين في الغرب راي يرى بانه يتفاوض مع
بوتن ليسحب قوته وراي اخر هذه فرصه
تاريخيه لانه هذه النقطه الاولى النقطه
الثانيه بالنسبه لقوه الذي كان يريد ان
يبعد الناته عن حدوده اذا به يجربه فنلندا
والسويد 200 عام السويد 200 عام وحيده
فيلندا 100 عام وحيده قوه بغبائه الذي
يعتبر البعض القيصر يقوم باخسار روسيا
اكبر موروث سوفياتي وقيصر سابق هذه الدول
لولا الغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا لما خرجت من
الحياد هنا الغرب حاول اقناع بوتن الخروج
من اوكرانيا رفض اقرا رفض بوتن ذلك وهنا
بدا الحديث بانه لا حديث اليوم معبوت
وفعلا بوت عقب في وجه اي نقطه السلام
ورائها البعض فرصه صالحه لعمليه تاديب
روسيا في اوكرانيا وتقليم اظافرها ولكي
توضع روسيا بالحجم الوضع الحقيقي عمليه
قرار منح اوكرانيا السلاح الثقيل لها
دلاله مهمه كبيره جدا جدا لو راينا نوعيه
السلاح المقدم لاوكرانيا حتى نهايه العام
الماضي كان جافل واستنجر وهو حرب عصابات
لانه كان قناه عندها الغرب ان الروس سوف
يحتل اوكرانيا واكبر ما يمكن في الغربران
حرب عصابات عندما راوا الغرب ان الق
المسلحه الاوكرانيه بحوالي سبع شهور
تستعيد وتحرر اراضي اكبر من الدنمارك راى
بانه اليوم كي لا يعاد سيناريو عام 1921
وكان لا تصبح اوكرانيا عمليه ضحيه راوا
بان اوكرانيا هي حاميه اوروبا الشرقيه
والقلعه المنيعه وراوا هنالك امه اوكرانيه
تستقبل السلاح الغربي بعقول منفتحه وبقلوب
شجاعه فراها فرصه ولكن من الذي منح الفرصه
للغرب هو بوتين اما بالنسبه الاوكرانيون
حتى الان متمسكون بانه النصر بالنسبه
لاوكرانيا تحرير اخر شبر اوكراني
واوكرانيا مستعده ان تقبل الدعم من اي طرف
اما المصالح الاخرى كل من يدعم له حقه في
بمصالحه اما بالنسبه لاوكرانيا حتى الان
للعلم
لازالت تدافع عن نفسها وكل مره يكون عم
يتطور الحرب كلما نرى خسائر روسيه وفضائح
اكبر حتى وصل اليوم بان الجيش الروسي اصبح
يتعلق بمرتزقه واصبح اليوم خلاص روسيا من
السجون اليوم مرتزقه فاجنر هم من يقود
القوات المسلحه الروسيه هذه روسيا فراى
الناته هل هذه الروس كنا نحسب لها حساب
راوا بان روسيا انا الاوان بان اما تعرف
ما كانت الحقيقيه عباره عن محطه بنزين
للغرب وتسكت اما فعلا تكون ذهب الى
سيناريو اكثر اما موضوع الصين حتى الان
الصين لا يتحدث بكلمه واحد دعم لروسيا
جميل جدا دكتور نواف هل تستطيع ان ترد على
هذا الكلام
طبعا استطيع ان ارد واتمنى ان نبتعد موسخ
وانا اقول لك ان روسيا وهذا التوجه الطارئ
من قبل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ودول
التي تقوم وتؤكد تقارير خبراء حلف الناتو
انفسها بانهم وصلوا الى مرحله نفاذ
مخازنهم السلاح وان الوضع في اوكرانيا
يتجه باتجاه الانهيار لو لم يكن الروسي
ثابت وقادر على التحرك والتقارير تدل مره
اخرى اقول لك
ضباط و جنرالات حلف الناتو بان روسيا تبدو
انها تمشي بخطى واثقه وانها مستقره عسكريا
وسياسيا واقتصاديا وانها خالفت كل
التوقعات التي توقعها الخبراء الاقتصاديين
والعسكريين والسياسيين واصيبوا جميعهم
بخيبه امل والسويد وفولندا التي تحدث عنها
الدكتور محمد هم اصيب ايضا اصيبت بخيبه
امل من قبل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
التي تضغط الان واليوم منذ شهرين تضغط على
بولندا وعلى التشيك من اجل اعاده بناء
قواعد لتعمير طائرات المسيره واصلاح
المعدات وهذه المنطقه التي قبل ان تنقسم
تشيك سلوفاكيا كانت هي محطه لاعاده واصلاح
المعدات النازيه الهيدروليه منذ ثمانين
عاما اقول لك يا سيدي لولا ان روسيا تقف
الموقف الصحيح وانها تحقق كل الانجازات
بشكل تراتبي وتواتري دقيق وفق مخطط له لما
ذهبوا بهذا الاتجاه الطارئ لارسال كل هذا
العدد من السلاح وكل هذا الكم من السلاح
وكل هذا الكم من الدبابات والاكثر من ذلك
يذهبون باتجاه الضغط على المانيا لزجها
بالمحرقه الاوكرانيه من اجل ارسال طائرات
ومن هنا خرج سولسيوم امس وحدث وقال نحن لم
ولن نرسل طائراتنا وجنودنا الى اوكرانيا
الى الان ولا في المستقبل لانه يتذكر من
جده الذي اذا كان قائدا في حرب النازيه في
جيش هتلر الذي يتذكر بانه دبابات التي
اصبحت الان نمبر
تسميتها ان تحرق وسوف تحرق اقول لك يا
سيدي شوف
الدقيق الامر وانا كتبت عده نقاط مهمه جدا
تؤكد ان الوضع خطير جدا بالنسبه لهم لذلك
هم يحاولون وقف الهجوم الروسي ووقف الدفاع
الروسي يا سيدي اقول لك ان مفهوم مفهوم
المدرسه العسكريه في حلف الناتو لبناء
الدبابات لا تعتمد على العمليات الهجوميه
والعمليات همم اقتحام في عندما تكون
الدبابات او بحيث تكون الدبابات هي ال-
ال- المركز الرئيسي لتحقيق الانتصار
دبابات التي ارسلوها والتي تحدث عنها سواء
كانت ابراز او همم او همم
الدبابات نمور نعم هي دبابات من نوع جديد
متطور جدا وتطور جدا ويجب اخذ هذا الامر
بعين الاعتبار وهي تعمل في مجالات متعدده
المجال الاول هو انها تتوزع بين الهضاب
والتلال ولا تتحرك من اماكنها علما ان
دبابات لا تتميز عن غيرها من الدبابات
بانها تستطيع ان تعبر الانهار والامر
الاخر مكانها هو الكائن اين الكمائر في
المناطق الحضاريه والسكانيه وفي احزمه
الغابات لماذا يتحصنون ويخبئون هذه
الدبابات حتى لا يكشفها الروسي ويحرقها
الروس منذ فتره وضعوا تقديرات استراتيجيه
لهذه العمليه وهذه التطورات وهم متدربون
وجاهزون من اجل ان يحرقوا هذه الدبابات
كما حرقوها في ابان الحرب العالميه
الثانيه وهنا يجب ان نقول ان التوجه
الطارئ لهذا العمل هو من اجل ايقاف الهجوم
الروسي والتاثير عليه ومن اجل ايضا
التاثير على الدفاع الروسي وبصريح العباره
هذا امر مهم جدا ويمكن ان ياخذ بعين او
يجب ان يجب
التقنيات الالكترونيات المتطوره اذا هي
عمليه الضغط هائله وكبيره جدا تنعم عن
خساره
هذا عن الضعف والتخلخل الداخلي في
اوكرانيا وعن قضايا الفساد والاستغلال
هناك فريق عسكري يا سيدي ظهر في اوكرانيا
يريد ازاحه
وفريقه ونحن تابعنا الاستغالات بالنائب
وزير الدفاع السيد ابن كليو اييه ماشيينغو
وايضا نائب وزير التنميه والاقاله التي
اقالها الرئيس الينسكي لمسؤولين اخرين
وتحديث بعد التعادل
بس خليني نقاش سيد نواف بس يكون فيه جميعا
عم بيسالهم كل واحد في الشارع يا سيدي يا
سيدي عندما عندما دخل القوات الروسيه الى
اوكرانيا سمعنا الكثير من من داعمي روسيا
في العالم وكذا والله خلال 24
خلال ساعتين ما بعرف شو اللي بده يسقطوا
كده هذا دخلته السنه الثانيه كم يوم السنه
الثانيه همم للغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا وانتم
تزدادون غرقا في الرمال الاوكرانيه والامر
الاخر بمعنى
فيصل في تنحي الاسئله ابطال ولديهم هذا
الجيش العظيم ليش كل ما دق الكؤوس بالجره
بوتين وجماعه بوتين وشلته يبداون بالتهديد
بالنووي باستخدام النووي بشرفك بشرفك حدا
بيهدد بالنووي الا اذا كان مهزوما وضعيفا
ومتقهر شويه
لحظه لحظه يا سيدي كل هذا الكم تفضل يا
دكتور فيصل يعني انا لا ادري يعني عن جد
انت مقتنع بالذي تفضل
اخي كل هذا الدعم
بارك الله فيك على هذا الاعتراف يا سيدي
عندما يكون الامر بهذا الحجم وهذا الضغط
السياسي والعسكري والتسليح هل يمكن ان
نقول بان روسيا يا سيدي ساقتصر هذا
الموضوع ولا اريد ان استرسل فيه روسيا
مرتاحه على اخر شيء وهي تقوم الان
بالعمليه العسكريه الخاصه وفق ما خططت له
ويا سيدي تحقق جميع اهدافها ولو ارادت
روسيا انت تستخدم الاسلحه الاستراتيجيه
لدمرت اوكرانيا عن بكره ابيها والعالم كله
يعلم ذلك والاوروبيين باتوا يعلمون ذلك يا
سيدي لم تستخدم روسيا حتى اللحظه سوى
الالعاب الناريه في التعامل مع اوكرانيا
وهذا وسوف يظهر في خلال وقت قريب والان
نحن في مرحله انتقاليه خطيره جدا نحن هناك
تخوف من الانزلاق الى حرب كونيه لان هذه
الحرب العالميه لم تكن فقط حرف في
اوكرانيا الحرب العالميه هي حرب عده قوى
مع حلفائها وق اثر مناطق معينه بهذه الحرب
العالميه لكن التاثير الحقيقي هو عندما
ينتشر على العالم كله سياسيا وصحيا
واقتصاديا وعسكريا الا تدري انه هناك
ملفات المختبرات العسكريه البيولوجيه في
اوكرانيا الى تدري ان هناك ملف كورونا
الذي سوف يكون ضجه عالميه كبرى لهذه
الجريمه الكبرى في هذا العصر هذا الجزء من
هذه الحرب الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ومن
معها من قوى العميقه
نصف دقيقه نصف دقيقه نصف دقيقه اتفضل نص
دقيقه لو سمحت تفضل روسيا روسيا لا تستخدم
الاسلحه الاستراتيجيه الان في وقت الثلج
حتى تحمي اكبر عدد من الارواح البشريه وهي
تتعامل بقمه الاخلاق وهي تتعامل لم تكن
روسيا هي روسيا الشيوعيه التي كانت ارعبت
العالم وتخيفه الان روسيا هي الدوله فعلا
وصلت الى النموذج الدوله العظمى وتتعامل
بكل القيم الاخلاقيه والانسانيه بكل هذه
المشاكل انا اريد ان اقول لك هناك هناك
ملفات خطيره جدا بيد
روسمه الدوليه بفعل الارهاب
الحقيقه
يا دكتور هذا الكلام للدكتور
محمد فرج الله دكتور محمد فرج الله كيف
ترد على الذين يقولون ان هذه الحرب الان
بالنسبه لروسيا هي حرب
جوديه وروسيا تعلم ان خساره هذه الحرب
تعني في نهايه المطاف
بتفكيك روسيا وانهيار روسيا وتحولها الى
شرادا فهذا يعني بعباره اخرى روسيا لن
تستسلم روسيا ذاهبه الى اخر المطاف اه في
حربها ضد الغرب وضد اوكرانيا وضد كذا هل
وضعتم هذا المنطق الروسي او هذا التفكيري
الاستراتيجي الروسي في اذهانكم في
اوكرانيا عندما تحاربون روسيا يعني روسيا
لن تستسلم ضعف اعتبارك روسيا لن تستسلم
والامريكان يستخدمون مستعدون ان يحاربوا
روسيا حتى اخر جندي اوكراني انتم عباره عن
ادوات في مشروع امريكي
يذبح اوكرانيا
يعني يبتز اوروبا وين هيك اوروبا
الاوروبيون حتى الاوروبيون الان غير
مقتنعين بكل الحرب هم عن ادوات تخضع
للابتزاز الامريكي وانت تعلم من الذي فجر
اا ال- ال- خطوط الغاز نورج ستريم 2 بين
بين روسيا وبين اوروبا هناك ضغط امريكي
على اوروبا للتخلص من الاعتماد على الغاز
الروسي كيف ترد على مثل هذا الكلام بعدين
روسيا يا سيد محمد فرج الله يقول لك حتى
الان روسيا
تحاربكم في اوكرانيا وتحارب الغرب بالعرض
ناريه لسه الاسلحه الاستراتيجيه للساده
محطوطه بالجونه كيف ترد
تضحك ها كويس شكرا طيب تفضل الان اريد ان
اطلعك على بعض العبارات والجمل التي
يسرقها الروس من الامريكان وينسبها
لانفسهم كلمه على فكره تعبير لاظروف ان
الغرب سيحارب روسيا الى اخر جندي اوكراني
للعلم هذا تعبير امريكي ايام الحرب
الشيوعيه الفيتناميه وقيلت من مسؤول
امريكي بان روسي
سيحارب امريكا لاخر فيتنامي حتى الروس
يسرق العبارات ما الغرب هذا اول الثانيه
اخف عن كلمه الاخلاق يتحدث عن الاخلاق
راينا اخلاقهم هنا في بوتشا واربين عندما
حصرنا هنا في كيف شهر ونصف وانا كنت من
اول الذين زاروا بوت شواربين مع القوات
المسلحه الاخرانيه وراينا المجازر وراينا
فعلا الدمار وزال موجود والله سالت من
صديق اوكراني سالني هل الجيش الصهيوني
يقوم بمثل هذه الجرائم عندكم فلسطين قلت
له قلت اما اتمنى ان اقول لك نعم
في سرقه لو في اقمار صناعيه وصور وثقت كيف
كان ينهبون المحلات والبطاطا موجوده على
المدرعات جاءوا عريانين جعانين
محمد يعني
جيش السوري تعفيش بالضبط
وهنالك
مصطلحات ايضا تزعجك
[موسيقى]
دكتور محمد كمل جيش تعفيش كمل انا لم انا
لم اقاطع انا لم اقاطع ارجوك ارجوك
دكتور محمد اسمح لي لكن
اسمحلي دكتور
انا لم اقاطعك يا سيدنا
الاوكراني بعض الاليات الروسيه عندما فجرت
وحرقت كانت تحمل ثلاجات وغسالات
هذا جيش فعلا مرتزقه هذا الامر هذا تعفيش
نعم واحد اثنين موضوع عشان الكريم لانجليز
لماذا سمي الان مشروع الامريكي في الدعم
الاوكراني الانجليزي اثنين هل تعلم لماذا
ازيدك معلومه لو عدنا الحرب العالميه
الثانيه الاثنين الروس او السوفيات
يتباهون فيها لولا مشروع لاند واحد الذي
دعم الجيش السوري بمد من السلاح الامريكي
لم استطاعوا ان يهزموا المينازيه الذي دخل
برلين هو الجيش الاوكراني الثاني
الاوكرانيون معروفون بقوتهم ولكن عاشوا في
السلام جاء بوت
غبائي ايقظهم الان وايقظه الان عسكريه
الاوكرانيه هذه النقطه الثانيه موضوع كذلك
ضغط على بولندا اي ضغط على بولندا بولندا
هي التي قالت لبرلين اما تسمح لي ان اسلم
اوكرانيا ليوبار اثنان او اقوم بتسليمه
بشكل مفردي اما موضوع تكلم عن البريطانيه
بالعكس معهد الحربيه البريطانيه اي اس او
قال ما تبقى اليوم من مخزون صواريخ كليبر
9% كل الخبراء العسكريين يقولوا في الجندي
الجندي في ساحه المعركه اذا قلل ذخائره عن
30% يتوقف على القتال وينسحب اليوم فقط 9%
من الصواريخ المجنحه كلبر الباقيه لروسيا
والتي استنفذها بوتن منذ طبعا تحويشه من
ستينات حتى اليوم يستنفيذها والغرب يراقب
ويرى فعلا الغباء العسكري والسياسي الق-
النائب اول نائب للرئيس الروسي وهو
اليكساندر روسي قبل يومين جنرالده قال
الحرب خاساسره وسيكون الان تبعياتها خطيره
وحرب اهليه داخليه على روسيا اما موضوع
السلاح السلاح همم طبعا السلاح النووي او
غيره دعني اقول لك شغله اكو عندما تنازلت
اوكرانيا اوكرانيا التي قدمت مثال بحب
الحياد والسلامه بموجب اتفاقيه بودابس
يعني ورقه ما لهاش قيمه بموجه عام 1994
تنازلت عن 2000 راس ناوي بضمانه امنيه
بريطانيه وروسيه للعلم وامريكيه ثم روسيا
خانه الاتفاقيه اليوم قالها ليستراس وقال
لها برج جونسون وكلهم قالوها ان فكرت
روسيا بتحريك اي مخزن من 11 مخزن من
السلاح النووي سوف تكون هنالك الضربه
استباقيه للعمق الروسي بالسلاح النووي
والعالم كله واوله الصين لن يسمح بحرب
نوويه ومعلوم بان بوت يعلم ذلك جيدا لذلك
هو فقط من اجل البروتوغندا والساحه
المغيبه وعلى فكره لو كان لديه طبعا يعلم
ان مسموح لا استخدم الناوي التكتيكي
والقياده العسكريه للجيش الامريكي في
اوروبا قالوا ان استخدم وله سلاح تكتيكي
هذا سيبرر لحلف الناتو الدخول على فكره
حتى الان النت يدعم بالسلاح زلين
الاستيقالها بالكونجرس لان نريد منكم جزء
امريكيين ولا اوروبيين نريد فقط دعم
بالسلاح لانه يدافع عن ماذا لانه دافع عن
اراضينا اليوم اذا فك ربوتا باستخدام سلاح
تكتيكي سيغرق اسطول البحر الاسود في دقائق
سيكون ضرب كل المناطق الروسيه المحاضره
الاوكرانيا وكذلك الدوله العميقه في روسيا
اليوم اصبحت اموالها مجمده داخل الغرب
وداخل اوروبا لن تصبر على قوه كثيره ويكون
عمليه الانقلاب والتغيير
دكتور محمد دكتور محمد
دكتور محمد هذه اخذ اخر كلمتين من كلامك
على انه همم بوتين في خطر نظام بوتين في
خطر وجه هذا السؤال الى الدكتور نواف
الدكتور نواف اسالك هل تستطيع ان تبرر لي
لماذا بدا النظام الروسي ينصب
مدفعيه والرشاشات على سطح الكرملين حتى
الكرملين اصبح في مهب الريح لاحظنا شاهدنا
في الاسابيع الماضيه شاهدنا الاسلحه على
سطح الكرم وعلى سطح المؤسسات السياسيه في
موسكو مش خايفين يا زلمه مش شو خايفين
عندكم كل شوي بتهددونا فيه ثانيا مقال
بفرن افرس يتولى بس خليني اكمل لك مقال
بفرن الثيرز الامريكيه يتوقع ان انهيار
نظام بوتن هذا العام والمقال ليس مكتوبه
من قبل الامريكيين مكتوب من قبل كاس فاروق
وهما الاول بطل الشطرنج المعروف والثاني
معرض روسي بعنوان نهايه نظام بوتين ستؤدي
الى تغيير جذري وتحول تاريخي في روسيا
والعالم توقع هذا المقال الانهيار العام
الجاري اذا استمر الغرب في تقديم الدعم
العسكري الاوكرانيا قائلا ان نهايه هذا
النظام ستكون مؤكده وان رو ستنهار لكنها
ستتحول الى بلد ديمقراطي لا يحكمه شخص
بمفرده او ديكتاتور او طاغيه بمفرده
كابوتا الذي الذي لن يسمح له الغرب
بالانتصار كما لم يسمح لهتلر كيف ترد
يا سيدي بيسان
جيش الروسي لم يتعامل كما تفضل الدكتور
محمد فرج وانا كنت اتوقع ان هذه الحلقه لن
تكون تعتمد على اراء شخصيه او اراء يعني
من باب لباب فقط من الشباك للباب كما يقال
اريد ان اكون الان اتحدث بشكل اكاديميه
الشوارع
ايه وانا رايت اخر رايت انت رايت في كل
مكان يا دكتور فيصل والله ترى كثير والله
يطول عمرك
شو عامله في سوريا الدجاج
لا يجوز ان تتحدث بهذه الطريقه لانك لا
تريد في سوريا الا ما تردوا وانا استخدمه
لكل حلقه نتحدث بها عن محور سوريا
يكفي هذا الكره ثواني بس يا سيدي لن يحدث
ما تحدث عنها الدكتور محمد هلا في القلي
راح الوقت مع تخليني اجاوب هيك حتى طلعني
امام الناس
لا يجوز يا اخي ان تتعامل
اننا سنلجا للاعتماد على تقارير دوليه يا
اخي خليني اكمل حتى لو ضيع وقت لو يحكي
كلام فارغ يا اخي انت هلا انا
زلمه
استفزني انت عندك اقسم بالله شهاده نوبل
بالاستفزاز وتضيع الوقت
لك يا اخي اكمل خلينا نكمل يعني اليوم ما
عملنا عملنا حفله تهريج يا سيدي بالنسبه
لروسيا لم تتعامل بهذه الطريقه التي تحدث
الدكتور محمد فرج وهناك في سوليدار يوم
امس كانوا يضعون الضحايا الاوكران في
صناديق خشبيه كما هو العاده والمعترف
ويرسلونها الى اهلهم لم تقصف روسيا حتى
الان المناطق المدنيه والى ما هنالك لا
اريد ان ادخل في السجال بما يخص سقوط
روسيا اقول لك بان الرئيس بوتين شخصيا
وروسيا الجديده وروسيا التي الان تواجه
وتقاوم كل هذا الارهاب العالمي الذي كان
سيصل بنا الى المليار الذهبي التي تحدث
عنه كل زعماء العالم بما فيهم الرئيس
بوتين هذه الخطه التي كانت لتدمير العالم
ولقضاء على البشريه لبقاء النخبه في هذا
العالم لتحكمه اذا كانوا يريدون الامن
والامان وحقوق الانسان في اوكرانيا
فليذهبوا الى المناطق التي دمروها في
افغانستان والشرق الاوسط التي يدفعون دمنا
الان ويعودون اعاده ذنوبهم يكفرون او
يدفعون ثمن ذنوبهم في تدمير هذه المناطق
ليذهبوا الى افريقيا والقرن الافريقي الذي
يموت من الجوع ويهدده الجوع والعطش على
اكثر 22 مليون بني ادم روسيا يا سيدي تعرف
تماما وتعي تماما انها في موقف المدافع عن
نفسها وموقف المدافع عن شعبها وعن وحدتها
وعن استقلالها هذا ايمان شخصي للرئيس
بوتين وهو امام الشعب الروسي كله لذلك
الشعب الروسي متضامن على غير العاده مع
القياده الروسيه ومع الرئيس الروسي جدا
تصرف الدولار جميل جدا
كلام جميل كلام جميل دكتور محمد دكتور
محمد انتهى الوقت باختصار الا تعتقد ان
هناك الكثير من المبالغه في الكلام الذي
يقول الكلام الذي نسمعه على لسان كاسروروف
او المعارض الروسي الاخر بان النظام
الروسي اصبح الان يعيش في الوقت الضائع
اليس هناك الكثير من المبالغه الكلمه
الاخيره باختصار
باختصار لا مبالاه ويثبت هذا الكلام كاتب
خطابات بوتن ار السابق وهو طبعا عباس قال
يانف والذي كتب مقاله عسير ان يوم الامس
وقال بان فعلا نظام بوت الانقلاب اصبح
فعلا حقيقيا بالذات بعد عوده الاف الجثث
الروسي الى الى طبعا اولياء امورهم النقطه
الثانيه لو دققنا فيه خطابات قوه الذي
يظهر مره مع جيش الروسي على راس السنه
ويظهر مع الامهات كلها خطابات مفبركه هو
في قاعه لوحده هو معزول على العالم هو
مرعوب من ان يلتقي مع اي من العامه وهذا
الرعب يفسره بانه اصبح لا يثق باي من
جنرالاته ولا بتخم السياسيه كذلك اليوم
الحديث في العنق الروسي بان عقبه السلام
والعدو الاول لروسيا هو بوتن وسيذكر
التاريخ بان روسيا مثل الفراعنه القدماء
كلما جاء قوما لعنه ما قبلهم وعندما سيطاح
ثبوت سي الروس بوت ان كان عميلا غربيه
ويحمله كل المصائب اللي عملها اشكرك جزيل
الشكر مشاهدينا الكرام لم يبقى لنا ان
نشكر اضيفينا من موسك والدكتور نواف
ابراهيم ومن كيف الدكتور محمد فرج الله
نلتقي مساله المقبل فحتى ذلك الحين وفيصل
القاسم نحيكم بندوحه الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]